hey guys welcome to the very the second
to very last evident Kaelin podcast ever
this year you don't want to say that are
you gonna do the same thing next time
when it's the last yes so in today's
podcast we're gonna be talking about
holiday life hacks we're gonna be
judging holiday things we're gonna be
talking about holiday traditions yay and
we're also gonna play some Christmas
Carol mad libs yes
I'm very excited let's start off with a
little bit of what's going on this week
in our lives we're working ahead on a
January project that's not because we're
on top of our game it's because we
realized so the project is a patio
related project and part of what we're
doing is refinishing the patio and as we
were buying things we really and it has
to be in January it's a Lowe's project
and there's like specific timelines but
what we realized when we were buying
stuff is it has to be applied in weather
over 50 degrees it's like the the period
we are in right now might be the last
three days available yes until the
project is published like if we don't do
it like right now we realize we already
pitched this it's scheduled we're
committed it's like we've purchased
things like so yeah like we're not
working ahead
we're like working down to the minute I
kinda like the last day available yeah
which is just like I'm just so glad that
we had the realization cuz otherwise we
could be in January and like I don't
know if stuff just wouldn't cure
yeah or if it would just be three times
as long I think would just it just would
never cure it would have a bad bond and
would it peel off eventually and then
like the days of work we've put into it
with would just be for naught that sucks
so bad yeah we realized thankfully we
you know we had a crazy month and a half
or so and then we started getting ahead
and then we realized there's all these
things we've been putting off and this
is one of them we realize that we moved
to the
had and he took care of it but if we
hadn't have like cleared our schedule
some and air quotes then we would be
like really up poop creek without a
paddle
so Kalyan has a few life hacks pulled up
I think that maybe all pull some up for
me
Caitlin you can look at those and we'll
kind of kind of go back and forth yeah
and judge them yeah I mostly want to
judge them I will say like I glanced at
a few mhm and okay I think we just kind
of go through the listen be like okay
like find stores that honor online
prices just like I feel like shopping
tips yeah I feel like that's just
shopping tips
I like pickup cooperative board games
these are these are like gift ideas this
isn't like holiday hacks I feel like a
hack needs to be like turn like using
something in an unexpected way affected
way this this is one that works
turn your pumpkins into snowmen doesn't
work if they're real pumpkins but if
they're like the forever pumpkins or I
feel like that's a little I mean well I
can't really judge The Nightmare Before
Christmas vibe because we have a Jack
Skellington combined pretty well I think
that you can merge those why does love
put Santa Claus hats not anything put it
on your tree that's what we did like all
of the statues they had their mishaps
yeah turn everything faster that's the
real life hack
the life hack is Santa Claus hats on
everything everything Santa Claus
yeah see this one I thought is good if
it works so you know how when you're
decorating cookies or when you're doing
like a gingerbread house the icing is
such a pain even when you put it in the
piping bags it often like bursts through
the bag or like you have to keep cutting
off the tip and then it just goes bigger
and bigger putting it in like condiment
squeeze bottles which are pretty cheap
we use them for okay would they
eventually jam though
I mean not if the holes big enough you'd
have to cut the hole at like the right
size anything will jam eventually
because I'm looking like like a mustard
thing and you don't wash it out enough
and there's like mustard tinted oh
speaking of cookies though one it's not
pulled up in front of us but one that I
read you know how something there's like
like a salt dough kind of thing that you
can use to make gingerbread ornaments
that smell good but you don't eat them
oh yeah yeah so that's like a thing that
people do one life hack was just take
old Christmas cookies and cover them in
varnish and hang them on your tree I
feel like that varnish varnish varnish
if you do enough coats varnish is like
fully waterproof like fully fully fully
sealed but but but there's already
moisture in there cuz it's a cookie so
what if it's like a fully dried cookie
like an old cookie like a year old
cookie cookies been on the elements like
that's already gonna have stuff growing
on it it's just mainly sugar it's not
though oh they're saying like an actual
cookie not an actual not like a sugar
like a fake shirt like I got so so the
salt dough yeah like it's just like salt
and flour right making play-doh yeah
but any normal cookie is gonna have
certain elements in there like butter Oh
like that'll turn rancid yeah that'll go
bad I wonder if like if it just turns
rancid it evaporates and then you're
just left with this dry husk of a cookie
that's just like a tank the recipe it's
a possibility yeah but I think that is a
good idea use the the condiment
squeezer things okay like making fun of
these things it's just like low-hanging
fruit invite your crock-pot to parties
this is another tip kind of related oh
my god secondary fridge when
all you need to do easy life hack is
just buy another fridge fridge yeah with
all of your money or all of the money
that everyone has just take all that
money the holidays you know that
everyone has extra money as much as you
can I don't agree with that it's like it
when it's fresh out of the oven was hot
it's like like Mike crispy yeah like
molten on the inside that is the best
exact time to eat baked goods
I just stock up on butter okay this one
it's a picture somebody's a picture some
don't it's a picture of a broken
wineglass pick up broken glass with
sandwich bread what is this a holiday
life whoops - that seems like a way to
cut your hand on glass the easiest
safest way to handle situation is to
grab a slice of Santa thread parentheses
yes comma really in parentheses no I
don't know I mean maybe you could like
if all that's left is the stuff that's
tiny enough you can't get in your desk
pan you maybe it'll like stick to it but
I feel like that's how you put your shop
vac yeah some of these might just be
like live hacks reused from other live
hacks like that's do you sale your
leftover chips by tossing them into the
oven for a few minutes
well how make it last a lure without
just make it seems like a bad idea okay
let's think there's like good ones
because I feel like that's a stroll for
a while like I could see that kind of
thing if you just do one maybe it's kind
of random but I could see let's say you
get different sized mason jars all
different sizes and you do it across an
entire mantel okay this is whole village
this is like getting down to like the
theory of the universe and what is what
okay
oh what's a life hack and what's a craft
well I think the reason that they're
saying this is a life hack is cuz you
are repurposing repurposing so it was
like I'm its edge of a craft
but like most life hacks are kind of
discs raft not everything like there is
one right here wrap Christmas lights
around a hanger so they don't get
tangled to be a hanger and I actually
don't think hangers would be very good
because they're sloped okay come on
we're gonna we're gonna link all of
these in the description of this podcast
go to the mental floss one go to item
number 19 it's use a laser projector for
your holiday outdoor life's hack life
act but also the picture that they chose
the worst Photoshop job I've ever seen
it's like there's no perspective it's
just all bad it's just like a flat image
of these Christmas tree laser designs
flatly projected across the house in all
of its different depths and the snow and
the sky okay this is this is a life hack
I'm not sure if it's a good one let's
debate it use hot glue to hang lights on
brick if you have clean brick maybe or
if but but if the brick is to clean long
stick oh yeah but if it's dirty it won't
stick if it's too clean what if it if
it's smooth enough it won't stick at all
and if it's really like rough I think
that you won't be able to get it off
there are some things that we have
applied hot glue to especially like if
you're using the industrial hot glue
that thing is that that stuff is tough
that is hard cuz yeah I feel like if it
was clean enough to stick it might not
go yeah it's like with hot glue there's
kind of two scenarios one it pops off
too easy or two it will never ever ever
pop off yeah and neither of those are
ideal in this situation use a command
hook to easily hang a wreath on the door
okay there's not like there's not the
standard thing to do I feel I also feel
like some of these was just like someone
trying to fit as many affiliate links
yeah get rid of gift cards you don't
want by using gift card granny don't
talk too much we did like you know when
we do products and stuff anytime we do
products it's like in our holiday gift
guide we get like I think we're kind of
obviously we're like these are products
that we like their affiliate with
holiday hack remember to take time for
yourself just do yoga in your bed in
your pajamas life hack life at ok you
know what
use green tinsel on your Christmas tree
to make a look for I think that's like
that's decent that's decent
you know tinsel there's a thing that you
can add to by the green pencil any
pencil any pencil makes your tree look
fuller but if you want it to look like
more branches look if you have a fake
tree you know we have a fake tree and
there's a few bare spots ah and I think
if you get green tinsel and wrap it
towards the base I could see that that's
like a good life hack I think I could
see that making it look fuller yeah baby
like I want to be very obvious like this
is tensile this is a the tree ours is
fake like once you hang ornaments and
stuff it kind of obscures the tensile
pencil like shiny I mean I think there's
different different types different
types I think like once you have because
I main thing is your eye ghost like the
bare spots where you can see through the
tree and I think if you kind of use it
to fill those so just kind of shiny but
sometimes like the branches on fake
trees are kind of shiny like ours has
kind of shinier ones in the middle where
it's like the cheaper stuff but then on
the outside it has the like what is it
called flocked slightly yeah there's
like oh no ours isn't look flocked it's
like a different it's like a like type
of fur like fur isn't the tree not like
if you are it's like where the ends are
split to make it look bigger some it
makes it look like a different type of
branch okay cool yeah anyways but on the
inside is just the cheap stuff and I
think you do that this is an interesting
life hack
I'll give someone credit for this I'm
not sure if it's good or not that's
interesting
string lies in the center of this tree
so it looks like it's lit from within
that could be cool okay they have a
picture it doesn't look good in the
picture but also it's like look in the
picture they linked this is the one on
BuzzFeed nifty or whatever they have a
tree it's lit from the inside that kind
of has an interesting effect and then
they just have like one sad string of
lights on one side and
I think the thing is so if you if you
have a fake tree without lights you
might be able to do that but with real
trees because like my parents always get
real trees wrapping it with lights is
like the hardest part especially if it's
a difficult tree and and that's just
when you're kind of like what if he was
the one big light at the bottom like a
single big light shining up to give it
like a little more oomph
but here's the issue it's it's easy to
do if it's like more bare but if it's
really packed which it being packed
would make it hard to like reach your
hand in there and wrap it tightly like
especially at the beginning when you
have a big bundle of Lights in your hand
yeah trying to like get it in there
that's really hard the string lights is
about it and if it's that dense than
just doing an up lighting it might look
cool the bottom but it's not gonna light
like all the way up yeah hanging
ornaments from light fixture to
transform it into a Christmas chandelier
it depends on how artistically you do it
the picture they include it doesn't look
that great you know what's a cool hack
what's that this isn't from any of these
but there's a sorry I'm jingling I'm
wearing my Christmas card and there's
like a cat coming out of my stomach
there's a plushy cat anyways um there's
a blog that I still follow them on
Instagram but I used to read all the
posts to have time called Chris love
Julia and one thing that they did you
know in Harry Potter like at the fancy
dinners and like the Christmas dinners
and stuff there's the floating candles
hmm so they did this really cool hack or
crafts where they get the little
battery-powered tea lights but then they
fit perfectly into a paper towel tube so
you put them into the top of the tube so
it looks like a pillar candle yeah and
then you like cap off the bottom as well
so it's not just empty yeah and you
paint it white so it looks like a
hanging candle and one thing I think
they did is they even dripped wax along
the sides of it Wow and then you hang
those from fishing line and like when
you have a bunch of them you know if you
just look at one that's what I like oh
that's kind of like cheap okay but when
you have a ton of them hanging from your
ceiling it looks so cool okay my problem
with that is it would look so cool for
one photo and for one evening
but replacing all of those like oh yeah
they didn't for like a party a party
okay it might have actually been for a
Halloween party but I think it'd be cool
for Christmas to like magic Harry Potter
vibe if you're like really into parties
and you want to make like a really cool
if you want to make a really cool like
statement piece I think that that would
be a good one yeah yeah this is this is
horrible it's so horrifying dip grape
stems in chocolate to make realistic
trees for a gingerbread house so bad it
looks like you know that looks like you
know that a monster from Nightmare
Before Christmas the one that lives in
the lake the gooey one he's not maleic
but yes that's what that's what it looks
like it's just like brown goopy like are
you supposed to add green to it somehow
oh that looks kind of cool okay okay
freeze whipped cream on a cookie sheet
and use a cookie cutter to make hot
chocolate hearts that was cute totally
cute can you freeze whipped cream like
to a point where it's cuttable more data
is needed I mean another option would be
because there's recipes for homemade
marshmallows I wonder if you just make
one big homemade marshmallow and cut
that found a method okay what store your
ice cream in a plastic bag to keep it
soft and ready to serve what I guess it
creates a better seal and it doesn't
create ice crystals
I like how they just say that and
there's a picture of ice cream in a bag
but like nothing is explained there's no
science link is there a link there's no
link there's no context store your ice
cream in a plastic bag to keep it soft
and supposed to believe this where is
the scientific data
where are your receipts it's just like
in the image itself it says found a
method to keep ice cream soft it doesn't
have to bend your spoon as soft as when
you first opened it every time
it's
well I read it on the internet I found
this image that means it's true like did
he not do any testing I mean maybe they
did testing but that's not it it's not
included yeah we use your leftover
Halloween pumpkins to make snowmen it's
kind of similar to putting the Christmas
hat on the pumpkin but the one in the
image looks better it's actually like
whole pumpkins not carved pumpkins and
they're white and they stack them these
are also doll this just makes me every
time we do this it makes me really want
to do a life hack episode because like
we like we need to test these hey I
think that's this one here isn't bad
right use old saran wrap or aluminum
foil containers - great - make great
boxes for gift cookies in their photo
they have like somehow obscure obscure
but obscure obscured the branding on the
outside of the box and it is like a good
width for a single row of cookies which
is a key way to present okay okay
question though question this is this a
great this is a great analysis of all
life hacks like you need to go through
this thought process whenever you see a
life hack they take something that
already exists these aluminum foil
containers or whatever and they're
repurposing it into something else
in theory good idea now if you just like
put the cookies in the aluminum foil box
and gave it to someone I think that'd be
a great use of resources but it looks
like these people went out and like
either painted or recoded or like
rewrapped the boxes in more material
yeah is that more wasteful or less
wasteful than just going out and buying
purpose-made cookie boxes hmm that's
interesting does he use like more
resources like like what what's the
point is it to be good for an
environment is it to save money is it to
save effort I don't think that this
passes any of those tests it's cute but
that doesn't look cuter than like well
it looks I'm not saying it looks cuter
than a cookie box but it looks when
you're like oh those used to be foil
boxes that looks cuter than a four that
looks cuter than a foil
oh yeah that's true yeah it's like in
theory a lot of these things might I
don't know pulverize candy canes and add
this magic to everything there's no
instruction though like what do you add
it to hot chocolate I guess ice cream Oh
actually that would be pretty good in
both cases
Oh cocktails cocktail ring cookies does
get your mousse sprinkle this on them
that's I mean that's that's a little
especially cause like sometimes you get
them in like Christmas gift baskets and
stuff and like what else are you gonna
do with them you might as well crush
them up yeah or turn them into name card
stands for your party which is another
life at I'm definitely seeing a lot of
these like the same way fasting on all
different pages you know I mean yeah
some are just like literally just like a
thing to decorate with just wrap things
with burlap um um the guacamole on pita
bread sticks no I'm not looking to take
pita bread you stick a stick in them and
[ __ ] guacamole in them
that's a festive holiday thing you know
that's a waste of guacamole okay now I
want to see this make gigantic Garland
this could be cool could be lame it
could be lame but it's also like kind of
cool in a way okay but the hack is if
you did it right the hack is make an
awesomely gigantic garland with balloons
plastic cups and ribbon what it is is
you have a ribbon you have Solo cups the
green that are green and that's supposed
to be like the base of the Christmas
light and then you have a big colored
balloon like glued or attached somehow
to the Solo Cup that looks like a big
bulb if they were lit okay we could just
use like string light as the string
punch like an axe in the back of that
and pop that'd be way better
just hanging it on a ribbon should we
test that should we make a video about
that should we do
Evan and Caitlin test lifehacks
Christmas edition
well test and improve life hacks cuz we
would like test it be like this is
laying in the weave I do want to do that
right but that could look kind of cool
any time in our schedule but I want to
do that next year I was like we have an
open slot no January no we could test
some life hacks in general yeah okay how
far into the podcast are we're 23
minutes and should we move on we should
move on to the game any like oh no any
holiday traditions
okay so holiday traditions let's break
this into childhood it now and in the
future in the childhood my favorite
holiday tradition in the childhood in in
my childhood was I think my mom reading
Christmas books to us the night before
the night before Christmas and there's
one in particular the midnight express
that the it's been a long time since my
childhood
we're getting old now I was like feeling
that because so many people in the
comments on our last video which was the
rainbow bent yeah we're making fun of us
for not or at least I think I was the
one that didn't know that you mix sugar
and kool-aid I just like it just it's
it's been a long time but I had no time
I used to have colloid well some cool
aids like you just buy the kool-aid and
it's like pretty done right I thought
some I think you used to be able to buy
it in like a bigger thing like country
time lemonade like that style yeah just
buy like a big plastic jug of who laid
and it was like pre mix with sugar
pretty mixed with sugar water everything
but but the packets you need to do
either the flavoring and the acidity and
then you do the sugar next at the top of
my head I for some reason I viewed the
packets as being like individual drinks
so you do it
so for those of you guys who may not
have watched the the bench episode we're
testing different ways to die wood and
one of the ways was by using kool-aid
packets which surprisingly works but one
of the things we tested when we are
mixing up the strong batch of that
colorant is we sipped it - and basically
since there's just acid and flavoring we
basically made oh my gosh my mouth is
watering right now basically made
liquefied warheads super sour candy so
much but it was also kind of fun yes
okay now back to childhood sorry so you
know the Polar Express was a fun story
and I also my parents got like the fancy
version which had like a little cassette
that you would stick into the cassette
player okay and you'd play on your like
boom box or whatever the heck you play
cuz that son I don't know and it'd be
like a soundtrack that would go along
with what my mom was reading and should
like skip actually like turn the page
you like move to the next part of the
you go to the next rap on the cassette
yes that had tracks how it know where to
stop it's just a continual loop right I
thought there were tracks father tracks
- okay anyways but I was cute and
there's like a little bell and my
parents would pretend that they couldn't
hear the bell ringing and my brother and
me and eventually my sister yeah we hear
the bell and my parents but we can't
hear the bell
we were like woah is that part of the
story like there's a special build a
special build up only children can hear
and when you hear the bell you believe
in Christmas and you get Christmas
presents well my parents don't get
Crescent pheasants because they can't
hear the bell
they didn't get presents from Santa they
might have I don't know but they
couldn't hear the bell and I felt
special this is a cute it's just one of
the cute memories that sit out I think
that might be one of my favorites we
like I don't know
had like specific things like that like
I remember always helping my mom like
decorate the tree and that kind of thing
and we would we would always have a real
tree so we would go out and like pick
out the tree nose I think my dad's
favorite part was picking out a giant
tree and then my mom would be like I'm
gonna have to wrap this but so we would
always like get a fresh tree and that
would be a thing I would sometimes try
to start traditions mmm
so like there's one and this I think I
was like more like pre-teenage not
really childhood I don't remember
exactly but I made these little boxes
that were small enough to hang on the
tree and it was like we did kind of like
a little white elephant type thing for a
couple years I've heard some of these
stories we did like some white elephant
things where prank gifts it was kind of
like prank gifts it wasn't intended that
way but it just turned into all of us
pranking each other quite often but we
would you know draw a name from a hat
and then you had to get a gift for that
person and it had to fit in the tiny box
so it couldn't be anything big and we
would open those like on Christmas Eve
so he's do it for a few years I don't
know what happened to the boxes maybe
might have gotten like lost in a move or
something and this isn't really a
tradition I just remember like when me
and my brother were younger I'm the type
that like I would want to spread out
Christmas morning and like really make
it like sleep in a little bit or like I
didn't want to I don't want to wake up
too early and then like when I did wake
up I kind of wanted to just like have so
much it's kind of like how you eat meals
you Kailyn has the smallest bites it's
like like if this was a cookie I might
eat this mouse I might eat like this
Mouse in three bites like oh this would
be like twenty bites for Kayla yes it's
the smallest of nibbles yes like a
little rabbit like oh I got a fox like a
fox eat my family they go a cat eat
Mouse
derail that conversation real good okay
holiday traditions childhood memories
but yeah so like my brother would get up
and like really want to get going and
I'd be the last to mosey on down and it
wouldn't even be like that late it'd be
like 8 a.m. but every what my parents
are awake because they wake up early my
brothers but I would want to like make
things fast and not getting too much of
a rush that's again it's not really a
tradition it's just me like trying to
like be contrary and that's still you
right now everyone down I haven't got my
coffee yet everybody hold on another
holiday tradition for me this there's a
lot of like event traditions that
revolve around food you know
Thanksgiving everyone has the
Thanksgiving food so strange that like
you're only gonna have this Thanksgiving
food once a year and that's the only
time you're gonna have this tasty tasty
food yep it's the same kind of for
Christmas for us like my mom makes this
really really good breakfast casserole
it's delicious it's so good I love it I
could eat that all year round yeah I get
it once we get it once a year stay
special but like it's a tasty casserole
I can't we just have their casserole
that's all the time can't do it it is so
good though it's like breakfast sausage
and just magic sauce it's like every
good breakfast thing thrown into a
casserole dish I think there's even like
a strange thing I don't like mushrooms
but I think there's like some sort of
mushroom soup just like the flavor yeah
but it's just like such a delicious
thing why can't I have it whenever I
like I am an adult you could make it I'm
pretty good cooking I could cook it
that's kind of like how my family and
this is like since I was really little
like all my memories include this my mom
makes homemade Chex Mix mmm
so good and it's it's like savory not
like sweet I feel like most recipes are
like sweet recipe no is it only at
Christmas that she does this or is it a
few times a year because I know
sometimes would visit at non Christmas
and should have that as it like a treat
it's it's always Christmas every now and
then it would be some other special
treat for a special occasion like
sometimes if we were there for
Thanksgiving but we weren't gonna be
able to go there extra yeah so so like
sometimes we would get it multiple and
then also I take home a giant bag of it
like we have in here
but it's it's so good there's so much
butter that goes into it and like we're
sharing garlic and like the best thing
is when it first comes out of the oven
and it's warm and like some have you
ever really put it back in the oven and
see if it heats up to be the same
lifehack I'm so excited for it though
because I just have it like for
breakfast and I've been doing this this
is like my my holiday breakfast of
choice is I have Chex Mix in a big glass
of milk and it's basically like eating
cereal except it's salty and with weird
that's weird but it's a weird
combination why like you don't just like
a hamburger with milk on the side you
know does eat what have you tried it get
it it's good but you don't only like
chips with milk on the side okay so
we're kind of bleeding into traditions
we have now what started with childhood
so challenge it and now it's continued
to now yes we still do some of those
things one thing we sometimes do off and
on is open one small gift that on
Christmas Eve in my family that's like a
minor tradition that we sometimes hold
to sometimes
mixed bag I will say it is it is
interesting cuz like there's like I
don't know when you're younger it's I
feel like it's easier to have holiday
traditions cuz you're like with your
family but now it's like we have
holidays with both of our families and
sometimes it's on the day and sometimes
it's like the day after cuz you know we
can't be in two places at work and it
does like complicate something yeah I
think one thing that that it's added is
on Christmas Eve sometimes one of the
kids will host everyone at their house
which i think is kind of a neat like
update to things it's like we are adults
now and we have our own places and we
can host people here we are host the
first time we hosted like Christmas Eve
at our house I felt very like I am an
adult now
I felt very glad that my mom
accomplished as an adult it's like look
we put out cloth napkins Wow but yeah I
do think that would be a cool thing to
continue I mean I think we've only done
it once your brother's done it most the
time yeah I think we're doing it again
this year I think oh yeah surprise like
make a lot of you yeah yeah yeah are
there any traditions that you would like
to start that aren't currently
traditions and it could be like with our
families or it could just be just us two
okay some things that I like in general
this general I have old I like fireworks
can we just are doing fireworks at
Christmas I mean a few days after oh
yeah that's true Christmas also
fireworks and the New Year's also
fireworks okay one thing that I wish was
was a thing for when we when we had half
million subscribers on YouTube we used
confetti cannons
I just like firing confetti cannons but
I like cleaning them oh yeah can someone
invent biodegradable confetti cannons
biodegradable confetti cannons that you
do outside we're like it's fertilizer so
what's the tradition you you just go out
and you pop them
everyone goes outside stands in a circle
and fires confetti cannons at each other
oh that's nice
that'd be fun that'd be a fun thing to
do that would be fun that there was one
Christmas when we lived in Alabama and I
remember playing outside like in the
sprinkler think of that because it's so
hot we were like it's Christmas and
we're playing in those sprinklers one
one thing that my brother and I did for
a little bit that I liked it and I also
thought it wasn't the most efficient
thing we would sometimes get each other
these really really bad remote controls
like I would get Eric a pair of two that
would both play with her Eric would get
a pair of two like remote control tiny
cars like control like little
remote-controlled vehicles of some sort
they were really cheap they had
interference issues they didn't work
that well and like we would just like
open them up plug him in charge them and
play with them for like 30 minutes and
like get lost eventually and never be
used again and it was fun but it also
isn't the most effective or good use of
thing it's like if a better Christmas
tradition might be the two of us get
some really good remote-control cars
that actually work and we bring them
each Christmas and race over the
presents and rappers and we met build
courses and stuff like that we used to
love stuff like that that'd be cool yeah
yeah but like why don't we just get some
good ones and reuse them every Christmas
I don't know they're the Christmas the
Christmas races if this is the new
tradition the Christmas races that's the
new tradition yeah and you guys just
race them through like all the obstacles
sounds pretty good we used to always
like the first thing I feel like the
first thing thing that we would always
go for cuz we would always get LEGO sets
mmm would be like because there's a
little bit of you know after you open
all your presents this one like use them
all well so no no oh no I I just want to
like as soon as I'm done opening I just
want to like get all the gizmos camera
play this new camera and I like shove it
in everyone's faces like adjusting the
camera see I'm like opposite there's so
many there'd be so many new things that
I kind of like didn't know what to do
first
mmm and so like my easy choice was I was
just always build Legos oh because I
would always get Legos and then that was
like a thing I could do to like ease
into all these new presents choice
overwhelming I I don't know when it was
but I remember watching Christmas videos
with with your family a little bit ago
and one of the things that you guys got
was this elephant that blue butterflies
in the sky and like you guys got that
present your mom helped you set it up it
works like three times and instantly
broke like instantly think of that one
viral video where like this this little
girl opens her present it's like a fairy
like helicopter basically so spins up
and she launches it it goes up in the
air and starts going towards the
fireplace Christmas here's a launch that
Barry does suicided like the reaction
everyone they're just like saw it coming
they couldn't do anything about it and
it was just like like such a good clip
guys was so good yeah thinking of
speaking of Legos and remote controls I
remember a long time ago we got this
really cool Lego set and it had like a
master control box and it had motors and
it had sensors and you could build like
a little robot you can program it with
custom code and everything and I'm like
man that stuff was so cool I wonder if I
could get one for Christmas like maybe
use it for project who knows or just
like tinker around with robots again I'm
sure by now they've advanced they're
smaller they're faster they're stronger
they're probably a lot cheaper like a
set of these things that's crazy
better they look like about the same
because I've gotten so expensive oh my
gosh yeah that's not do you have any
what are your favorite Christmas movies
I I don't know home alone in some ways I
like I like the parts where he's
building the stuff i the parts where
he's like doing other things I don't
like the parts with his family because I
feel so bad for his mom that like
bothers me so much upset she worked so
hard to get there and then the rest of
you I'm so upset how like she went
through all that and then the fight the
family gets there from there but I'm
like that just makes me angry angry
angry they come home and she's like oh
hi Kevin I'm so glad you're okay I'm
gonna leave you now and then she just
leaves them and then the rest of family
gets there Kevin Kevin
we like you now you're cool even though
we didn't like you before
and then
they are we - they leave it yeah walk
away
Jesus standing at the window thinking
WTF why did my family just leave me he's
like like a monologue in his head or
something by this bothers me greatly
I still like home alone even though I do
agree that I feel bad for them all I
like a lot of aspects of home own but I
wish that there's like a supercut of
home alone
he's like Kevin's just having fun family
stuff I don't like where they make him
feel bad I don't like where they bully
him I don't like when the mom gets upset
and it's like like a kid tinkering at
home and having fun home alone
destroying some bad guys just like do a
supercut of home alone and then I'll
watch movies you've seen a bunch of
times you kind of generally you can kind
of put them on in the background just
watch the parts you want know but not
Evan Evan can't like nope - no I can't -
now so you have to watch all of it
bothers me greatly I didn't realize how
much this bothered me until another
holiday favorite Grinch the cartoon line
okay time out time that one's good that
one's good it's like 20 minutes of solid
content yeah
solid content that was a tradition
that's like the one thing we would watch
every year good tradition elf elf is
good I also feel bad to be a little bit
of feeling bad for like the protagonist
at some point because like that you
usually any protagonist is a hardship oh
I'll give it like good marks
die hard die hard haha I like die hard
no there is difficulty there is like you
know persevere perfectly well executed I
did not feel uncomfortable during that
movie at all
I also just like watching like TV
holiday specials like the really bad
ones like the office or stuff like that
there's like 10 episodes of friends
Christmas yeah great you can just watch
like 250 minutes like friends how many
hours is that a few like 4 5 are you
doing the math for yeah four point one
six six six six six tickets are what
else what other like really stands out
for holiday movies I mean there are
there are others that I remember like
watching as a kid and liking but I
haven't seen them in so long
you're out Oh Christmas understand that
it's a classic button you know I
remember when I was younger I liked the
Santa Claus with Tim Allen and I liked
jingle all the way with Arnold
Schwarzenegger I'm sure those are oh my
gosh I want to watch theirs jingle all
the way with torch me I thought of that
it was like too tight but also you suck
at home remembering details of movies
more star wars are Wars quite like I
mean the recent ones especially but okay
I remember this one
I think cuz it wasn't part of a series
sometimes series really harder for me to
write my name oh you know it's a great
Arnold movie The Last Action Hero great
movie I was a good one okay so it's he's
like a dad and there's this really
popular toy does like the superhero toy
and so like the whole thing is him
trying to like get this toy for his good
and that's like the whole challenge
that's all really all I remember I think
about dresses I know this movie
Jodie the Logan up I can tell you the
whole flop if you
that's what's gonna say Arnold looks for
toy good summary we should do a whole
podcast of like Caitlyn summarizes
movies I'm pretty bad I'm like as bad at
movies as you are at lyrics so but I say
I think let me know if I did okay anyway
so good alright well you know we could
probably talk about this for a long a
lot longer but we need to make some time
for the games
yes so you move on to holiday song Mad
Libs yes okay so I have a few shall I
start you're gonna have to I set it up
so that like we can type in the blanks
so you should not look at the screen I
have lyrics split up and then like I
inserted blanks and then you have to do
a dramatic reading append of course Oh
dramatic soon yeah to the tune okay
first I need a type of music smooth jazz
oh no what can I take it back
okay no no no wait I should know no
first instincts only don't overthink it
I want to do dubstep but smooth jazz is
good too I mean you can whatever one you
want hear you there's another one so you
can do that one for done so the type of
music changes part way through our way
through just because I felt like it
plural noun oops verb verb oops okay
another plural noun pg-13 pg-13 no no
I'm trying to keep my my words like you
know the best type of Mad Libs is dirty
Mad Libs
yeah you know
hugs wait wait plural noun plural
I guess that is like hug a hug is a
thing but plural noun dollars okay and
another verb hug a noun go
all right in all caps a popular event or
just an event like the proper Super Bowl
okay I don't know I chose Super Bowl I
should have done like anything else a
plural noun cat's a verb
high-five yeah yeah okay another plural
noun treats in another room eat um two
more verbs that end in ing pooping and
eating and a location Lake no no I did
the famous lake that everyone laughs at
but I'm not gonna do that I'm not gonna
resort to that type of humor Paris okay
I thought you showed it on Lake Titicaca
adjectives no sorry stinks um I do want
to do or do I do whatever you order line
what am I do something that describes a
noun um happy so risky okay one more
adjectives um
excited wow this is very not pg-13 at
all a verb squeaky why he'll have
something not fit if you want my Navi
gee baby I'll give you something not
meet you at their team know those word
not pg-13 oh oh oh oh because they were
but happy and excited I could get good
like I could raise the rating of the
song no you you could do whatever you
want I'm just so making fun of your a do
something okay I'm gonna push it
creative then the word happy which is so
lame cuz it makes perfect sense in a
Christmas moist there you go what is it
earlier I was like holding myself back
yet you said humping egged me on ing
humping swimming animal bunny and a
known dog yeah this needs to be more
specific a vehicle a vehicle surfboard a
noun surfboard no no no we need two
nouns a singular and plural laptop are
you looking around the room and things
cameras okay hey I draw inspiration from
many different sources Caitlyn okay over
the ends and ing filming okay come on
you gotta try to burbs vlog like that
okay another verb um posting it doesn't
end post
okay just post and a noun
last one Instagram are you ready for the
rendition of jingle bells smooth jazz
yes
jingle bell jingle bell jingle bell
smooth jazz jingle poop scoop and jingle
bell Jingle dollars hug snowin and
blowin up bushels of gold now the Super
Bowl has begun jingle bell jingle bell
jingle bell jingle cat's-eye 5:00 and
jingle treats eat what an excited time
it's the right time to go swimming in a
one bunny surfboard cameras jingle
around the filming vlog and posting the
jingle and feet which is just a weird
line in the jingling feet that's the
jingle bell Instagram I don't I wrote
the blanks but I don't remember what is
like where so this should be equally
good order to start off with body part
butt cheek um noun beard beard I'm
honest I'm just not even like checking
the context of it and this is gonna be
what's gonna be I mean you can check the
context cuz some like I changed
surfboard from just like a noun to a
vehicle cuz it like oh that's so much
effort I was put anything this group of
people team ten no verb fart fart verb
dance dance noun
cat hair name Evan noun slime noun so
many nouns earwax body part chins ok now
but in an important now I'm an important
now yeah this is a big noun okay I
choose wisely
Oh God okay back fat no reduce rear oh
no no rear all beautiful bacon ah yes
that's that's what I'm looking for
that's what I'm looking for that sign of
energy I want okay oh my gosh this is
gonna be good
I'm having to type it in a few different
places so I don't mess this up you know
what one of the very first things I
programmed ever Katelyn it was a mad
libs generator C++ and III wrote the
stories and it would prompt you to enter
a nouns and everything like that and you
could like say like I want this one this
one this one this one so it's like you
entered the menu you had multiple choice
of different stories it prompt you for
all things and then spit out like a
story that's really good thank you I
don't know where it is
it's probably in some folder somewhere
adjectives beefy oh yes yes yes yes I
like it
adjectives stinky thank you thank you
adjectives thick
yes very nice group of people
Kevin's nah nice verb provoked whoo nice
adjective Harry verb I'm trying to not
repeat things like yeah hey what are you
trying to say but I repeated I think
that is a good time say barf barf yeah
adjectives fluffy person or character
like James Bond or um Hello Kitty and
then one more person or character the
supervisor ding ding ding
the song is complete ready for
processing and singing let's hear it
ok this is my rendition of Frosty the
Snowman mingled with Caitlyn's words
Evan the bacon man was a jolly beefy
soul with the stinky cat hair and a
thick shins and two eyes made of beard
Evan the bigger man is a fairy tale they
say he was made of a slime but the
Kevins know that he provoked one day
there must have been some earwax in that
old hairy happen found through with he
place it on his butt cheek he began to
barf around of Evan the big man well as
fluffy as he could be and the team tends
said he could barf and ants that's the
same as Hello Kitty and the supervisor
I love the earwax hairy old hat that I
placed my butt cheek that made me barf
okay I don't think we have time for
another round of this because the
podcast is getting long did we save the
next two for next yes we have two more
times
stay tuned to the last podcast evident
Kalyan are ever gonna make this year
which will be next week or so I think
yes so stay tuned for the exciting
conclusion but for now time for thing of
the week so my thing of the week is
probably something that not everybody
needs it's a specialized tool but I
really really like it is an RGB w le d--
light and it's really small it has an
insane battery life and the cool thing
about it is it is adjustable in terms of
warm light cool light it can do the full
spectrum of all of the different colors
it's really small it's really bright and
it's just so interesting as we keep on
filming in different situations and
experimenting here and there and
developing new types of content it's
really interesting trying out different
techniques the other day we weren't
filming in our garage and I needed like
the scene to be you lit a little bit
brighter but in the garage we have
everything at a very certain color
temperature and I need to light this
next scene right to match the color
temperature of the room that I was in
and if I was using any of our old lights
it would be a harsh contrast between one
source and the other source and with
this light I was able to get to the
exact right warmth coldness balance
level and it blended right in
and it made the biggest difference and
like I was like oh I totally make sense
and I get all these things and it was
just like a big aha moment for me and I
think that in the future I kind of have
this like on the underdeveloped thought
of filming like gear content in their
garage but I want the set to look
different so I'm like thinking about
maybe different colored lights or ways
to make the scene look different and you
know just continuing to experiment with
new
forms of technology that might take our
content to the next level and I think
this is gonna be one important piece of
kit that we take with us and I think
it's gonna be good like let me travel or
we're not able to have all of our big
lights maybe have one or two of these
with us to like still get a good level
of quality of picture even when we're
out and about
what's it called is bowling it's a
little bit expensive it's just like I
really like it it's just a few things
that I thought were cool about it and
like I'm not as big of a tech person as
you are but these are a couple things
that you haven't mentioned yet about it
that I think are really cool one it's
like a really sturdy aluminum casing
it's really solid it feels like if you
like it could handle being dropped a
little bit you know like because it's
like all aluminum that it has a good
mounting system that's really really
really cool aluminum like super sturdy
it's just like high quality sturdy
battery life yeah it recharges via USB C
which is so important you can travel
around you can plug it in and leave a
running wall you're like supplying power
to it and we have run it for like four
hours maybe and it still had battery
life left yeah cuz we were using it I'm
going back to like what we're talking
about right here when we were working on
the patio we like it got dark out but we
had to keep working to finish the step
we were on and so we just brought it
outside now let the whole patio yeah and
it looks like the reason why instead of
bringing other lights out is because it
mounts the tripods we were able to raise
it up high get a good angle and
everything good for filming a long time
lasts a long time and it's the most
portable and it's the most easy to
recharge it's just it's just neat that's
cool okay my thing of the week is a
channel that we started watching and it
was just like in our recommendations I
don't know why I originally clips
I think it's cuz we've started watching
slightly more commentary channels every
now and then watching like some more
commentary channels yeah and so it's
it's kind of a commentary job there's
like some escape a lot of good like
original humor and so the channel is
Drew Gooden and yeah he does like
interesting comedies but I really like
his humor because it's so funny it's
it's it's like kind of dry and cheesy at
the same time you know what I mean and
it's like very clever humor and he
incorporates a lot of like funny skits
or like I don't know I just like really
like his style and it's like commentary
but and he's being funny but it's also
it's also very real and down-to-earth
it's not like presumptuous or anything
yeah he just seems like a normal person
you know his channels like decently big
he's like 1.9 million subscribers or
something which always we always go back
to like there's so many channels that
I've never heard of that are like really
good content big and really good and
they're just floating out there yeah so
like the first one that I watched and
this is cuz I was just kind of like
curious about it it was like a
commentary on like Lily sings like late
night show so if you guys don't know
Lilly Singh is another like very big
youtuber superwoman is like her channel
I guess me and she's not someone who we
watched but like yeah I know of her and
she started started a or she got like
her own late night show and like you
know we're always curious to see
people's experiences with like YouTube
versus TV and what ends up happening
with that and I think they're like
what's what might have been the easy
thing to do is just take shots if
someone but he really analyzed that I
didn't even watch at Caitlyn washer but
she told me about it but what I think we
like that he does is he analyzed that he
takes a step further he analyzes the
whole situation he's like can YouTube
content translate into TV and do the
audience's go back and forth and what
are smart and like decisions and stuff
like yeah and he did take some jabs at
why it was bad but also like why it like
the situation led to it being bad and
also like giving her the benefit of the
doubt on certain things but it was also
it's like funny but
like not not just because it's like
cheap job after cheap job after cheap
job like it's funny but also interesting
commentary and insight I don't know it
was really like I'm also you just really
good ads really good yeah he was really
funny ads yeah drew Gooden will link to
his channel and Evans fancy RGB lights
yeah hi guys
thanks for tuning in to another evident
Gatling podcast I hope you enjoyed this
one I hope you're having a great holiday
season so far hope things are wrapping
up for you guys and you guys get to
spend some quality time with family soon
there's one more podcast for the year
and then we're gonna take a break around
the holidays
[Music]